Hallo Guten Abend, mein Name ist Aydin. Ich bin hier als Assistentin der Synthetik und heute türse ich ständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Ich würde so erst ein paar Fragen zur IRR Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Guten Abend. Gute Besserung Frau Doktor. Sie hören sich aber auch nicht gesund an.
Ja leider. Aber ich fühle mich sehr gut. Nur meine Stimme ist weg.
Ah, sonst sollten Sie als Patient oder als Arzt auch nicht arbeiten, wenn Sie krank sind, ne?
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich fühle mich sehr gut. Ich war krank seit zwei Wochen, bin ich krank.
Also Sie stecken mich jetzt nicht an, oder? Ich bin jetzt auch krank und nicht, dass ich noch extra krank werde.
Aber ich bin nicht mehr als Stekend. Ich glaube, deswegen arbeite ich jetzt.
Nur habe ich eine Heiserkeit, habe ich keine andere Syntheme.
Dann du tsche ich Ihnen eine gute Besserung.
Vielen Dank. Danke schön. Ja, wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Mark.
Könnten Sie Ihren Nachnamen buchen?
Mark ist mein Vorname. Martha, Anton, Richard, César, Mark.
Und der Nachname ist Frisch. Frisch. Mit S-H.
Ja, genau.
Okay. Herr Frisch, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
Was sind Sie genaue Geboren?
Ich bin geboren, 26. Juli 1974.
Okay. Wie schwer sind Sie?
Wie Sie sehen, sehr schwer. Ich wiege ca. 130 kg.
130 kg?
Ja. Leider.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube, ca. 1,75 m.
Okay. Was fühlst du uns herrfrisch?
Ja, ich komme, weil mich meine Frau etwas gedrängt hat.
Ich habe hier am Unterschenkel eine Wunde.
Die wird immer größer.
Meine Frau wollte unbedingt jetzt, dass ich damit zum Arzt gehe.
Okay. In welchen Unterschenkel haben Sie Wunde?
Auf der rechten Seite.
Aber links fängt es auch schon langsam an.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Wunde?
Auf, das geht schon länger.
Das erste Mal ist es ungefähr vor 2 Monaten aufgetreten.
Als ein kleiner roter Fleck, aber das ist jetzt sehr groß geworden.
Wie groß ist diese Wunde momentan?
Ich kann es Ihnen zeigen, das ist so groß für die Hand-Innenfläche.
Ich würde mal sagen, ca. 10 cm.
Im Durchmesser.
Und diese Flecken sind genau rot?
Oder gibt es eine hellere Seite?
Oder gibt es Eiter auf dieser Wunde?
Ich kann Ihnen das Bein gerne zeigen.
Das war zuerst rot.
Dann ist es etwas flüssig geworden.
Das wurde immer größer.
Die Oberfläche ist etwas schmierig, etwas gelblich.
Vielleicht ist es auch eitrig, so wie Sie sagen.
Und es nestet die ganze Zeit.
Immer wenn ich eine Verband mache, das wird immer sehr schnell nass.
Herr Frisch, ist diese Wunde auf der Wunde oder auf der vorne?
Am Schienbein, meinst du?
Ja, das ist im Unterschenkel an der Seite zwischen Schienbein und Wunde.
Oberhalb vom Klöchel.
Hatten Sie einen Trauma vor dieser Wunde?
Was meinen Sie mit Trauma?
Haben Sie sich verletzt?
Ich kann mich jetzt nicht erinnern.
Okay.
Wurden Sie von einem Sekunden oder einem Rücken gebissen oder gestochen?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Okay, Herr Frisch.
Seit zwei Monaten haben Sie diese Wunde.
Tut es Ihnen weh, haben Sie Schmerzen an der Betrufung?
Ich merke keine Schmerzen.
Ich sehe aber nur, dass es jetzt seit drei, vier Tagen ungefähr
fast der gesamte Unterschenkel sehr rot geworden ist.
Ja, und da hat es langsam, jetzt merke ich ganz wenig Schmerzen,
aber ansonsten hat es bisher überhaupt nicht weh getan.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass in Ihren Blinken auch ein Wunder ist.
Ja, das fängt so langsam auch an.
Wo ist diese Wunde genau?
Also da ist es auch im Fuß rücken.
Fuß rücken.
Okay.
Herr Frisch.
Hatten Sie früher ein bisschen Werte gehabt?
Nein, nein, so habe ich später noch nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Vermutung vorhanden?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Herr Frisch, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich bisher nicht gehabt. Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie internetseiten ab oder zu genommen?
Also ich spiele meinem Gewicht, war ich nicht ab und zu mal zu
und ein bisschen ab, aber eigentlich ist es gleich geblieben.
Herr Frisch, okay.
Haben Sie Fernwertis durst?
Brauen Sie...
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber ich drück eigentlich immer regelmäßig.
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, dass ich mehr trinken muss.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fernwertis wassallassen?
Ich habe Sie nicht verstanden bitte.
Nein, ich habe mehr Fernwertis.
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich muss mehrfach am Tag auf Toilette und
zum Wasser lassen.
Manchmal auch mal nachts, aber weniger.
Wie oft müssen Sie in der Nacht auf die Toilette gehen?
Verhältn... Also einmal vielleicht, aber nicht immer.
Ich nehme mal. Okay.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Frisch?
Ich bin sehr gut.
Ist ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Sehnen?
Nein.
Ich habe eine Brille, aber die habe ich schon seit langer Zeit.
Okay.
Haben Sie Taubheiz gefloh der Krippen an den Beinen?
Hab ich nicht gemerkt, nein.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein, Herr Frisch?
Ich merke eigentlich nichts, mir geht es eigentlich relativ gut.
Sie haben keine andere Becher, ja?
Zwischenmerzen habe ich jetzt keine, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Herzrasen?
Atemnot, ja.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Herzrasen?
Atemnot, wenn ich mich halt anstrengere, wenn ich mal Treppen steige, merke ich,
dass die Luft etwas knapp wird, aber Herzrasen habe ich nicht gehabt, bisher, nein.
Okay.
Wie... wie schlafen Sie? Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Nein, ich kann gut schlafen, damit habe ich keinen Problem.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stuhlfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß, nein, ist nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Frisch, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorler-Krankung stellen.
Haben Sie irgendeine wersche chronische Erkrankung oder wichtige Vorler-Krankung?
Ja.
Können Sie mir sagen?
Ja, also ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck und nehme Medikamente.
Seit wann haben Sie...
Das weiß ich nicht so, das sind vielleicht schon 10 Jahre.
Seit zehn Jahren.
Wie Sie sehen, ich habe ein bisschen Übergewicht.
Und ich habe auch Zucker.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Zuckerkrankheit?
Das sind auch ungefähr zehn Jahre.
Seit zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Oh je, da muss ich mal in meine Liste gucken.
Ich kann mir die Namen nicht ganz merken.
Für den Blutdruck ist es Ramie-Prie, fünf Milligramm.
Eine morgens, eine Abends.
Dann habe ich Amlodipine, zehn Milligramm morgens.
Für den Zucker habe ich Med-Formin, 1000 Milligramm.
Eine morgens, eine Abends.
Und dann habe ich noch Amaryl, zwei Milligramm.
Können Sie wiederholen?
Amaryl, nennt sich das.
2 Milligramm, eine morgens.
Das ist für den Zucker.
Okay.
Und dann habe ich noch was.
Ich habe hier Simvastatin, 20 Milligramm.
Ich glaube, das ist für Kollisterin.
Ja, 20 Milligramm, Abends.
Ja, genau.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nee, an sich nicht.
Nein, das ist doch genug.
Das ist schon viel zu viel.
Häufig ist Ihr Blutdrucker gut eingestellt?
Ja, ich habe es auch.
Mein Hausarzt kontrolliert das regelmäßig,
aber der ist nicht so zufrieden.
Er meint, er ist immer zu hoch.
Okay.
Achten Sie auf Ihre Ernährung nicht so viel?
Ich versuche es, sag ich mal so.
Ich habe auch versucht, ein bisschen abzunehmen,
aber das klappt nicht so gut.
Okay.
Ich laufe jeden Tag sehr viel.
Ich bin Postbote und trage Briefe aus.
Damit laufe ich schon sehr viel.
Sport mache ich nicht.
Okay.
Aber Sie laufen regelmäßig, jeden Tag?
Ja, jeden Tag.
Ich verteile Post.
Okay.
Kilometer jeden Tag.
Ja, sehr schön.
Ich habe ein Problem mit dem Nieren.
Ich habe es mir auch schon sehr gut gemacht.
Nein, also für die Lambo-Werte waren die Nieren immer sehr gut.
Okay, sehr schön.
Nur der Zucker ist ein bisschen hoch.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, das ist doch genug.
Ja.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ich habe mal ein Knieproblem gehabt.
Da wurde am Knie auf der linken Seite.
Ich hatte mal so ein Kreuzbandriss.
Und was hatte ich noch?
Ja, an der Schulter auf der rechten Seite.
Ich hatte mal Schmerzen.
Und habe Spritzen bekommen.
Nur Spritzen.
Okay.
Wann war dieser Kreuzbandriss?
Das sind ungefähr sechs, sieben Jahre hier.
Sechs, sieben Jahre.
Okay.
Die andere Eingriff, Schulter Spritzen, wann war das?
Fünf Jahre.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, herfrisch?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube schon.
Geh genau Corona?
Ja, bin ich auch schon.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergie?
Nein.
Ja, herfrisch rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Seit wann?
Oh, seitdem ich 16 bin.
Okay.
Wie viele Sekretten rauchen Sie täglich?
Es ist ungefähr eine Schachtel.
Eine Packung.
Ja, es ist auch so viel.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nicht regelmäßig, nein.
Können Sie etwas genauer sagen?
Wie viel Mal pro Tag trinken Sie?
Also nicht jeden Tag.
Alle zwei, drei Tage mal zum Glas Wein.
Und manchmal ein Bier.
Ein Glas Wein oder ein Fleisch Bier?
Ja.
Okay, herfrisch. Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Wie Drogen?
Ja.
Nein, wie kommen Sie da drauf, Herr Doktor?
Ja, das ist eine Routine Frage.
Wir stellen diese Frage an unsere allen Patienten.
Ach so, nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt über Ihre Familien erfahren.
Haben Ihre Eltern wichtige Erkrankungen?
Also mein Vater hat auch ein Diabetes und hohem Blutdruck.
Und meine Mutter hatte Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Die hat, glaube ich, auch irgendeine Operation bekommen,
muss Medikamente nehmen, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht was.
Ja.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist gesund, ja. Also sie lebt sehr gesund, sie ist schlagspotlich.
Und soweit ich weiß, hat sie keine Medikamente.
Okay.
Herfrisch haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Wo ist sie allein?
Sie sind meine Freundin zusammen, ja.
Okay.
Sie sind Postbote von Beruf?
Ja.
Ich glaube, ich habe alle erforderliche Fragen von meiner Seite gestellt.
Müssen Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, vielen Dank.
Es war sehr nett von Ihnen und freundlich.
Was ist das am Bein?
Muss ich mir da Sorgen machen?
Ist es etwas Schlimmes oder?
Ja, herfrisch.
Ich denke, Sie haben eine Wunde wegen Ihrer Zuckerkrankheit.
Was?
Ja, Zuckerkrankheit können solche Wunden führen.
Aber das kann noch andere Infektionen sein.
Ich glaube, es kann auch eine wachsgewebe Infektion sein.
Ich werde sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann grabe ich ein paar Laboruntersuchungen.
Dann können wir wieder sprechen.
Okay, alles klar.
Sie meinen, es ist nichts Schlimmes.
Ich muss jetzt nicht operiert werden, oder?
Jetzt kann ich das nicht genau einschätzen.
Aber ich glaube, es ist keine Operation.
Es ist eine Medikapherapie.
Was ist Medikapherapie?
Medikamente, oder?
Medikamente.
Okay, alles klar.
Gut, dann schauen wir mal.
Was ist Medikapherapie?
Ja, okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Gut, dann schauen wir mal.
Okay, gut, vielen Dank.
Noch eine Frage.
Hatten Sie eine lange Reise gehabt?
Nein, nein.
Ich war jetzt nicht verreist in letzter Zeit.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ja, und Kollegen.
Keine Fragen?
Haben Sie beide geschwollene Beine?
Ja, wir sind ein bisschen geschwollene.
Und für die nur annämmnese Solomere fragen,
leben ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, ja, die leben beide noch.
Und meine Füße weiß ich nicht ob sie kalt sind,
aber ich spüre das nicht.
Sind Sie deswegen bei einem anderen Arzt,
zum Beispiel, ihr Hausarzt?
Gehen Sie nur zum Hausarzt, nein.
Wie viele Kisten werden Sie zum Schlafen?
Nur einen Kisten, das reicht mir.
Wie viele Treppen steigen Sie?
Also wir meinen das, wie viele Treppen steigen Sie?
Ich wohne im zweiten Stock.
Ja.
Aber ich muss langsam steigen.
Als das geht, können wir anfangen?
Einige Sekunde brauche ich.
Eine Frage.
Siehensieh immer dicke Socken an.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich kann keine dicke Socken anziehen, da ist es mir zu warm.
Zu warm, ja.
Okay, ja.
Ich glaube, ich kann anfangen.
Ja.
Okay.
Guten Abend.
Ich möchte Ihnen unseren neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ah, unsere junge Kollegin.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Sie sind immer noch heißer.
Ja, leider, aber ich seh es mir gut.
Danke.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Dann legen Sie mal los.
Herr Markfrisch ist 48 Jahre alt.
Der Patient ist 130 kg schwer und 1,75 m groß.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns.
Seit zwei Monaten.
Ich stehe an dem Progredientem.
Linkseite.
Wunde im Unterschenkel.
Rechtsseite.
Ja.
Wunde im Unterschenkel.
Der Patient erwähnt, dass die Wunde.
Ersteinzentimeter in Duschmesse sein.
Und im Lauf der Seite.
Vergrößert.
Ja.
Aus der dem.
Habtet der Patient.
Aber kleinere Wunde auch in ihrem linken Unterschenkel.
Trauma.
Peristasy wurde verneint.
Die Wunde oder die Lesion.
Sei rot.
Schmierig und Schmierig gelblich.
Und.
Ja, naß.
Patient.
Leide.
Seit sehnjährn.
Und die Abites mei.
Frühe.
Habe.
Die restliche.
Die.
Ja.
Und die.
Bei ihm sei keine Alergie bekannt, sie ist eher vollständig geimpft.
Bei den Patienten liegt auch eine Nikotinabussus vor.
Er rauhe seit 16 Lebensalter einstattet Sekretentäglich.
Er trinkt auch regelmäßig Alkohol.
Alle zwei Tage trinken ein Glas Wein oder ein Flasche Bier.
Roggenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er darf regelmäßig.
Die Familienanamnese Ergab, eine Diabetes-Melit,
sowie eine Artillerie per Tony-Beinfatter
und eine Herz-Rismüsüstörung bei Diamutter.
Die Patientin hat eine Gezündung der Schwester.
Er ist eine Ergab-Partnerin, die die Anamnese ist.
Er ist eine Post-Po-Tefamberuf.
Ja.
Die Anamnese ist die Anamnistische Angabe der 4. Amn-E-Histin.
Auf eine Diabetes-Melitus-Ferurzart.
Ja.
Die Diabetes-Melitus-Ferurzart, Polinöropathiehin.
Und Diabetes-Schäfung, Diabetes-Schäfuss,
Konchessakne, die Lesion ist im Amn-Untaschenkel.
Deswegen die Diabetes-Melitus-Ferurzarte Wunde.
Wie nennt sich diese Diabetes-Ferurzarte Wunde?
Vorhin kam der Tipp nachlesen.
Ja, ja, Urkuskuris.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ja, gut.
Das ist eine oder Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose oder erste Arbeitsdiagnose.
Ja.
An welche Differenzialdiagnosen denken Sie noch?
Das kann noch ein Cellulit sein.
Oder TVT kann auch infrage kommen.
TVT.
TVT, ja.
Das ist nicht so hoch wahrscheinlich, aber ja.
Was noch?
Tromboflibitis.
Tromboflibitis, genau.
Der Patient hat berichtet, dass der gesamte Unterschenkel
ganz rot geworden ist seit drei Tagen.
Woran denken Sie?
Ja, Cellulitis, deswegen habe ich da auch Cellulitis.
Das ist noch so ein Hautinfekt, so ein ausgebreiteter Hautinfekt.
Hautinfekt?
Ja, ja, das ist gut.
Ein Irrsäle, jawohl.
Irrsäle.
Gut, welche Untersuchungen, wenn wir jetzt nochmal auf unsere
Arbeitsdiagnose kommen, Sie gehen von einem Urkuskuris
bei Diabetes aus.
Ja.
Welche Untersuchungen brauchen Sie jetzt?
Ja, so erst Labor Untersuchung.
Ich werde Bulut Bild, Entsündung sparamäten CRP,
esgi, istimilnasun, Bulut Suka, natürlich.
Und Algemain, Sustant, Nirenverte, Leberverte.
Ja, war mank.
Verde, ja, istimilnasun.
Und ja, umainen, Tifafti, Auszuschliessen,
natürlich, ein Dehdimler, vielleicht.
Okay.
Probei bei dieser Wunde kann der auch mal so positiv sein.
Ja, wegen.
Okay, also Sie machen Laborwerte, welche Untersuchungen sind noch notwendig?
Ja.
Sonografie, der werde ich durchführen.
Und rundgen.
Sonografie von was?
Ja, Sonografie des Beins.
Wie nennt sich das? Was was am Bein möchten Sie sehen?
Duplex Sonografie, aber so sieht sich Gewebez Sonografie.
Nicht das Gewebe, aber Sie möchten eine Duplex Sonografie, um die Durchblutung festzustecken.
Sie machen eine Duplex Arterien und der Venen.
Sie wollen zum einen sehen, ob er auch eine PAVK hat, oder wie gut die Durchblutung ist.
Und ob er eine Venöse Insuffizienz hat, eine chronisch Venöse Insuffizienz.
Sie machen eine Darstellung der Arterien und der Venen vom Unterschenkel.
Davon hängt es ab, wenn er eine zusätzlich Durchblutungsstörung hat.
Was zu vermuten ist, denn er ist Diabetiker, er ist adipös, er raucht und hat eine hohe Blutung.
Er hat viele Risikofaktoren für eine PAVK.
Wenn er da einen Verschluss des Unterschenkels hat oder eine Verengung,
dann wird der Wunder schlecht heilen oder gar nicht heilen.
Wenn er da einen Verschluss hat, eine hochgradige PAVK,
dann müssen Sie diese vielleicht sogar mit einem Stand öffnen,
damit der Wunder auch heilen kann.
Deswegen ist eine Ausschluss von der PAVK wichtig.
Und die Venöse Insuffizienz auch noch mal nachschauen.
Sie machen einen farbkundierten Duplex sehr gut.
Was macht man von der Wunde?
Diagnostisch oder therapeutisch?
Diagnostisch, wir sind immer noch bei der Diagnostik.
Ja, rund kann können wir auch.
Kann man machen, genau, ob die Knochen betroffen sind.
Ja, und wenn ich wissen möchte, ob keine.
Können wir ein Abstrich machen, um eine Kultur anzulegen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Haben andere Kolleginnen oder Kollegen noch Ideen oder Vorstellungen,
was man mit diesen jungen Mann machen kann?
Keine Antworten.
Ich glaube, das war sehr gut.
Das war sehr gut.
Und auch die Diagnose war richtig.
Aber die Polyneuropathie ist auch eine zusätzliche Diabetes
sehr spätfolge.
Aber das, was der hat,
wahrscheinlich jede Diabetiker hat auch eine Diabetes-Serie.
Aber die Diabetes-Serie,
die Diabetes-Serie,
die Diabetiker hat eine Polyneuropathie.
Das kann man auch vom Neurologe untersuchen lassen.
Aber erst, wenn die Wunde dann abgeheilt ist.
Man würde erst sagen,
das ist ein Ulcus Chloris, eine offene Wunde.
Und du schaunst auf Aufkarnias,
ihre Verdachtsdiagnose.
Meine Verdachtsdiagnose war schon richtig.
Ulcus Chloris bei Diabetes.
Aber Sie müssen immer nach der Durchblutung gucken.
Oder eine Durchblutung nachschauen.
Das kann sein, dass er beides hat.
Ja, deswegen, Artilli Cartoni,
die Diabetes-Serie.
Ja, genau. Sehr gut.
Sind Sie schon Fachjaztin?
Ja, Anästhesistin.
Anästhesi, sehr gut.
Die Anästhesi.
Wunderbar.